you know what you know lady dogs don't
lift their [ __ ] legs up yeah that's a
guy dog day [ __ ] dude welcome to
another episode of gangland my know we
are out here you guys already know what
we're here for we're looking for the
best tacos in LA now this spot has been
featured by numerous people but I will
say this still before it was featured in
those [ __ ] things
Vince poori you teeth the resident East
LA Japanese Mexican Hannah
way before that we become enough bodies
ghost Jalisco for anyways okay there's a
car coming here by the runners over
under my heel kill a bug we've been
coming down to [ __ ] [ __ ] man that's
quite funny don't you think
come on
I'm just chunky toe so we've been coming
out to money's ghost Holly's goes for
quite a while I now know they have a
special team here and it's going to be
there okay yeah we gotta go hello it's
for sale by the way it doesn't know
everything video you know what [ __ ] the
trailers guys [ __ ] killing me man you
know what you won't you're not into
parking there man anyway we've been
coming out the muddies ghost at least
one for a very long time and you want to
hear the funniest [ __ ] so Vince hit them
up on Instagram and let them know or to
ask them as we come out and film them
and we put this whole like professional
like email out and what they responded
with was hey because there's Tsukasa
[ __ ] up a name that means that they're
down so we're gonna show you guys what's
up with Maddie's clothes Jalisco one of
the best taco joints out it was
typically the shrimp dawdled tacos is
what they're known for
so come on with me
[Music]
alright guys so we ordered the food and
I am super hyped to talk about this
place number one I know what you look at
this - you're not when I said tacos you
weren't really thinking about this right
so as I mentioned before melon and I
were talking about this when you think
about tacos or just any kind of cuisine
in general right saying that tacos in
general aren't only supposed to be one
thing it's kind of weird to say that
it's like for example right if we said
oh I want agent food people s you want
Chinese you want Japanese or whatever
right well different regions in Mexico
make different styles of food so like
when I first had this like shrimp Dorado
taco right so it's kind of fried as
crispy and the reason why he was asking
us to eat it real quick cuz we don't
want to get rid of that crisp so they
have an own little special sauce to mix
right here we got that spritz of lime
soft delicious creamy pieces of avocado
and they had their specialty like shrimp
inside there so I want you to take a
bite of this finish now this this is
their tacos de cámara so comment on it
come alone is like shrimp Padma oh
excuse me a comment on yes right oh yeah
over here
[Laughter]
there you go she has a white spot in her
pants right yeah I do yeah yeah it's
good right
oh my [ __ ] goodness the first bite
instantly you can taste all the
ingredients then it's not greasy what do
you like about the mother I love lime so
putting that lime on top it first hits
you there and then you got the
creaminess or the avocado then you taste
the meat inside and then the crisp
options and then after you take a bite
you're like you think it'd be so oily
and greasy but then your
oh no that's just really refreshing Oh
crunch oh so you'll just don't know what
to expect when you eat this right and I
feel like mmm I don't know really what
the highlight is I like everything about
it
I like the texture I love the sauce on
top I love the creaminess of the avocado
and the stuffing inside I don't know
what's inside it actually what's that I
feel I don't know some kind of starch
and it's shrimp but I want to ask them
cuz I'm gonna think I secrets and stuff
I don't wanna go ahead of step my
boundaries or stuff i unders but I got
to tell you what is that right what I
don't know it was like Mexican
Thanksgiving
I don't know but seriously I feel like
that I'm eating Thanksgiving food cuz
you know in one bite you wanna get the
turkey the the cornbread the stuffing
the cranberry sauce the mashed potatoes
in one bite has all that stuff right
this is it it's salty you know if you
want a little more acid it'll spread
that lime on it Oh what are you doing
right now I've been saying this on every
single episode if you're only going to
those like small little joints out there
they have a roof oh that like go to
these truck spots man I need to come out
here to East LA Boyle Heights I suggest
you do it in the daytime and remember to
got to get yourself a pop a proper how
deep those this right here son I got the
line would you get no you got a water
what a damn trying to be healthy
whatever that stuff is inside the size
of the shrimp killer mm-hmm I love it
and when you have like extremely salty
food you always want something to cut
cut it in between like I said it's that
perfect mal instead of acid salt and fat
and heat I love it did you check that
[ __ ] out on this on a Netflix by the way
I love that show which one it's called
salt fat acid I'm like that and that's
that's what this is right here not
afford why I like you so much you know I
mean now if you guys don't already know
I'm
huge oysters fanny I'm saying when you
from California say it like that
what's the earth Sam California oysters
this is called there if you see it on
the menu is called a panade O's and I
guess that's just a made-up word from
what we found out he's like coming over
your hair it was what they called it
what they got here they got a little
sauce on that they got their self a
little comedone a little shrimp what I'm
gonna do with that is Emma mines right
there right dere right which one you
want you want to Octopussy or you want
to add a little heat to it real quick
right there you know I'm saying it I'm
gonna take this Forks you could take
that spoon take that big s food that
forked experts I'm gonna cheers it broke
waiting here then the boss you know
saying got it then we go slurps you go
and you eat oysters and I had like a
really weird like extremely like seafood
II tasted it doesn't seems like the
ocean that's not clean that means that
voice turd is bad spit that [ __ ] out you
could actually get sick from it it
happened to me a couple times so when
you had this oyster right you could tell
right off the bat fresh it's like just a
mouth full of like ocean water you know
I mean it's like creamy clean refreshing
clean is the key clean octopus I still
can't wait adjust that that's in me
anyways
octopus is really tender he's not
treated at all it has a little bit of a
bite to it I love it that she's not
going to date Lee yeah no I'm not yes
you are she's gonna go on a date later
too she's ready dude
she's already okay ready fellas ever
since that other video I've been getting
times at the ends
oh really well I thank you David what
have they been saying dirty things no
just like pictures or like mama like
just like stuff like that I don't get I
don't get dirty pictures I love that
like I could never say what's up mama
and then have somebody look back at me
and be serious hey mama does that take
you look better yeah that's what it
comes out yeah I got it yeah right then
that's right you better call me father
next okay right here this is called
their comput Anna so if you had like
shrimp cocktail like you get like in
like a Mexican restaurant it's like that
same like tomato base but in this they
got mixed seafood in here they even have
those oysters in here as well so it's
like this personally ten times ten this
is times ten
we got pieces of octopus yeah we got
avocado we got that tomato in there and
we got some scrimps - I believe
somewhere that you up scripts - this is
not octopus you know what this is my
friend this is a bologna suntan they be
hooking people go man they literally
demolish the whole sea and put you know
why they don't let crammed people in the
Monterey Bay Aquarium in there here we
go I love the only kid at the field trip
that went like this what are you buddy
yeah why don't you stop cursing right
how about that whoa wow that's delicious
and when you guys do this to you we just
I want you to first eat it like straight
up like this but of course you had like
your little tostada stuff right here but
I actually like it with a saltine
cracker son you don't crumble it in
there like some white people clam
chowder
right and this right here we call that
the piece de resistance
my turn my turn no you got to dance
after this
oh yes Rio [ __ ] bless you thank you
how'd you like it the saltines hmm right
mmm am i right Yeah right
mmm I think my foods hit different notes
but it makes it so you could just
constantly eat it more and more you
don't want to be too heavy I don't want
to be like too acidic like it just makes
I think I just want like a couple bites
from those pet foods but if you have
something like this it makes you want to
go back for more and more because we're
talking about balance you know like any
Koreans eaten mm-hmm I would eat this
yeah yeah this is impression yeah when
you look at this is a little filling but
because of all like that protein in
there and we have it with the practice
it really fills you what you'd be
surprised um can I get some writes a
noodles up in here your mother
bastardize this food is [ __ ] well we're
gonna move on from this because we don't
want to get too full on that because we
got to go right here to actually my
personal mmm-hmm I thought the Dorado
taco was my favorite thing here but it's
actually this dish right here so this is
their Poseidon right so they're Poseidon
is very much like their ceviche and agua
chili mixed together if you haven't
enough what you live before I should
have spicy yes [ __ ] and I'm usually seen
the gun with like raw shrimp but this
the recited has a little bit of
everything here we had those avocados we
got there octopus in here we got there
ceviche so we have here coming back yep
as a disclaimer if you do get the
Poseidon or you get the hug what you
like it's gonna be hot as hell it's
going oh boy hot so I'll go chili
literally means like firewater and you
could dress it up however you want you
can get it from the tostada from the
bottom but we got some extra stuff here
to open your mouth meat and one two
three here we go
it's spicy mmm how was that tougher it's
it's um it's happening yeah well out
it's worth the burn though one more time
you can get into real quick look at that
right there
and here we go this really helps the
spiciness yeah okay we got oh I'm so
sorry here we go uh-huh
I don't know how you're doing it it's
just good I'm sweating like a
[ __ ] right now here oh my I
thought I was playing huh I'm acting up
for camera too spicy as hell right now
did you know let my poop too much they
look just like this and that's not in
from the spices of the blood I kid you
not this spicy right but it's so good I
love spicy this bicycle doesn't ah spicy
would be so remember people like I said
before come out to these spots we are
out here in Boyle Heights slash East LA
and this right here if you're looking
for that seafood like Jalisco spirits
come to Mauricio Jalisco it's like this
very simple looking truck out here no
frills but the food is gonna have you
craving for more all the spots that I
feature so far do have something very
unique to offer right and I want you
guys to kind of think about like going
things outside of just those tijuana
style tacos like I said I loved he'll
want to stop tacos but there's more to
that than that right
yeah I dare you oh damn already no big
ass oh you are pretty damn loud that was
[ __ ] loud
I asked you when I said in love to go as
loud as you're gonna be in you lied I
lied blew out the mic [ __ ] yeah me up my
friends whoo we got there what the [ __ ]
is this food is like an Asian parent
parents level parents almost Asian purse